[Music]
can you guys imagine
huh a city that
is all futuristic
it's a 100 mile long city 100 miles
yes and it's one straight line
whoa okay one straight line like one
street
like one street yeah have you seen the
there's no streets there's no cars
have you seen the islands in dubai where
they made palm trees
what do you mean by a straight line a
straight line
like how wide is a line hopefully pretty
wide like one building's length
two buildings length 100 miles by one
flight
yeah i'm like that's a really just one
sidewalk hopefully it's like a boardwalk
you got both sides with you know
buildings and then
it's like main street but all the way
down wow so
the claim is that you can walk uh like
everything that you need will be within
a five minute walk of home
but your home and that getting from one
end to the other would just take 20
minutes
but 100 miles yeah how how's that
possible transitional movers
transit yep yeah so there's this thing
called
the spine that will it's like the yeah
people movers
i will show you a video yeah show us a
video what are they building this
human brain cannot understand let me
answer that question before i play
the video so this will be in saudi
arabia of course
and the crown the saudi crown prince
mohammed
bin salman is the one behind this
project
and here we go
contemporary cities couldn't cope with
growth
[Music]
it's one of these dramatic ones we got
[ __ ] on all the cities
[Music]
instead of over it what if
everything you needed was always a
five-minute walk away
what if invisible technology generates
carefree and open
urban space
what if sustainability was not a goal
but a given
what if we replace outdated urban
services with new services
driven by artificial intelligence
what if we built the line
[Music]
a 170 kilometer revolution in urban
living
protecting the earth's most stunning
nature while creating
unmatched livability
[Music]
so it's gonna happen that's pretty tight
that you could be in the city and you're
in the middle of nature at the same time
you have to love that the saudis are
doing this who
made all their money from [ __ ] oil
that's the reason why
no i know it wants to move away from
it's hysterical
yeah they want to move away from the
dependence of oil and so they want to
do something more um like
self-sustained and all that stuff and
being part of the nature
and so the crown prince was saying like
how cities have
have always built around like after the
industrial revolution cities prioritize
machines cars and factories over
people and so he wants to
he wants to focus more on people he's a
younger
guy though like he this is a newer guy
he's more progressive
well a lot of the countries have to
figure out a way because the oil is
going to run out
so they're planning that by the time a
lot of these new things are built
that becomes the new economy and tourism
and all that stuff yeah so this is what
he looks like
yeah he's new yeah and so he was saying
that by 2050 i think he said
that commutes are going to be horrendous
people are going to be
just the environment's going to be
horrible
and so they want to move away from
relying on
oil and so it's really interesting
because he's saying that a lot of this
is going to be
ai driven and that there's going to be
an artificial moon
artificial rain robot maids why would
they need an artificial moon
that's interesting it just launched one
i don't even know
oh this next one is glow-in-the-dark
sand is just because he wants it
that's cool and then there's gonna be
like flying taxis
because he wants it jurassic jurassic
park style
uh theme parks have you not seen the
movie bad things happen no
these are robot dinosaurs has he not
seen terminator bad things happen
i robot i know this seems like a really
fun theme park i want to go check it out
dude iridescent santa in yeah so is it
meant to be for
tourists or for like people who live
there like residents
1 million people can live here this
sounds like what walt disney wanted to
do
but he didn't have the money yeah if
only saudi prince
hooked up with walt disney walt disney
was too
like it was too small he wanted to make
suburbia basically just in disney well
they did
yeah florida they did what's it called
again i forgot i don't know we talked
about it here on jk
i don't remember but uh anyway this this
city is a 500
billion city okay 500 billion
that's how you say it 500 billion dollar
city and it's
it's gonna be in a northwestern corner
of saudi arabia
and that currently it's a desert but
that it won't be for long because they
plan they plan to use
cloud seeding to make it rain and stuff
like terraform it right this never would
have happened if the old guard hadn't
died off
and had like we like the sand yeah
because no uncle we need to
change cause what's wrong with sand i
love the sand oil is our [ __ ]
business dude
this is amazing they're also saying that
future citizens not interested in
visiting the farmers market will instead
be able to make reservations at a
michelin star restaurant
which neom aims to have more per
inhabitant it already has a michelin
star and it hasn't even been built
that is [ __ ] safe and sustainability
dang you're thinking about the future
they pay for those [ __ ] things you
can't go
off-roading though because you can't
have a car
outside of the city where are you gonna
park park those things
leave it outside in the sand yeah with
all the lamborghinis out there yeah
this is the kind of place that can only
exist when there's like a king or
something because it's like
to guarantee everything is walkable
you're like
this this business has to be here period
yeah
you can't just have someone like start a
business you have to give this a
michelin star
who will kill you we'll [ __ ] kill you
you
what do you think's dumb-ass happen
maybe three
yeah how are you gonna guarantee more
michelin
star restaurants per inhabitant than any
other people if you're a king you could
do like
every business just government owned
then it sounds like it and also
they mentioned this other article how
buried in the 2
300 pages of planning documents there
are plans for the forcible relocation of
local tribes
the creation of human gene editing
clinics and
24 7 government surveillance listen
it's worth it we're saving the
environment okay [ __ ] they're making
a sustainable city okay
this is for the future are you serious
right now are you not with the future
you're gonna go against a sustainable
city yeah someone's gonna make an e-book
about living there and
we'll give the tribes a casino that's
what they do every time right right
and then this this other part says uh
that means while you're chilling on the
glowing beach daydreaming about your
next prefix
meal a drone equipped with facial
recognition technology will likely be
transmitting your location to neon's
1984-s
law enforcement officials i'm down
sounds pretty damn good to me
yeah sounds so fun you're just chilling
hey at the cost of living inside of a
[ __ ] screensaver from the future
you have to have your picture taken yeah
okay i'm down are they going to deliver
me hot dogs on a [ __ ] drone
they probably are yep yeah cause they're
saying that
uh a computer can notify crimes without
having to report them or where all
citizens can be tracked
the computer will predict the crime that
you're going to commit and throw you
into a [ __ ]
prison we will execute you for the crime
you recommend now they're just going to
have drones
shooting people on the beach sunbathing
because wait wait wait don't worry
they were a criminal they were about to
be hey
a michelin star restaurant just open up
right there
stepping over bodies okay cool dude
thank you hey bud you're stepping on the
body that's glowing too
under yeah
but i would want to visit i hope it's
done by the time we're still alive
like i know right this is already better
than dubai and dubai was where i wanted
to go next
i'm like holy [ __ ] i looks next level
it's next it is
they have indoor snowboarding yeah
that's how [ __ ] crazy it is
well yeah and then the gene editing
clinics they're saying that it would
modify neon citizens to be stronger
not to mention smarter meaning
that they'll be creating a city of the
future
but not only a city of the future but
also of humans as
well i keep watching movies like
jurassic park and gadakis and they're
like
you know i've learned a different lesson
everyone else here
yeah he's pulling the wrong lessons from
these movies
that's the problem what was that dr
something's island oh yeah
yeah dr moreau i learned dr morrow yeah
where he would have
people stay and it's like paradise but
they're like experimented on and [ __ ]
sounds like one of those situations yeah
is that a movie or show no brando was in
that movie yeah and he's
he showed up and he had no idea what the
[ __ ] was in the script or anything
and he showed up and he was like super
overweight and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] or maybe i got that mixed up
with uh
with that war movie wasn't that the
scooby-doo island movie
kind of like that too zombie island what
yeah
i don't know they did something like
that too they did it for zombies
attracting people to go to this island
but then it turns out that it wasn't
that this sounds like a scooby-doo thing
it's not quite what it seems yeah yeah
i'm gonna stay in america
the city of the future dude i just want
to live somewhere that has a taco bell
a you know what i mean like they're all
pretty decent and close and like they're
pretty new they're like a big one you're
in paradise now
yeah that's what i'm saying i'm not
gonna taco bell ralph i'm gonna chance
it i'm gonna get my face scanned every
five minutes i'm going somewhere
i don't know for me it's like i scan my
own face when i take selfies
i want to go somewhere and feel a little
bit
of that like control you know like
tourism
like i want to go to north korea but
then we talked too much [ __ ] about them
so now i'm scared
[Music]
[Music]
you